what do you think it would take for
reconciliation with your dad and also
your family
there's not there's not no there there
will never be
a reconciliation i think that um the
most that
anyone could ask for it at this point is
for everyone to go on with their lives
um as they see fit and
to just leave
the other
side alone but at this point um there
there will be no chance for
reconciliation
and
unfortunately i'm going to continue
to respond
to whatever allegations
are
put out and i just want to make it clear
in this interview that
the only time i ever say anything is if
i am responding to something if you want
to
speak and
for whatever to be heard or believed
then you have to be accepting of the
fact that the other side is going to
have something to say too i want to give
you the opportunity right now if your
dad was watching
what would you say to him what message
do you have for todd i don't have leave
me alone
leave me alone let me live
my life
i'm tired i'm over it um i
thought that i had moved on from that
part of my life and
it seems week after week that something
else is dredged up for
whatever reason or whatever agenda is
being pressed that week and i'm just
tired of it leave me alone
i wanted to start with your post from
july 27th and that's of course you
announcing that you and your husband
were splitting after nine years together
i mean first of all how are you holding
up
you know i think it would be
a lie if i said i wasn't sad some days
and happy some days you know some days
you wake up and it's gonna be a great
day and then some days you wake up and
you're all in your feels and
i'm just trying to take it day by day um
i have a little one you know he's eight
years old but we're trying our best to
do it together and to
understand each other's feelings um and
just navigate this with jackson in the
best way possible but also by taking
care of ourselves too absolutely now are
you still in communication with
jackson's dad like what is your house
how would you describe your guys's
relationship now i wouldn't say that
there's been a huge
change in communication the
communication just looks differently
you know now we're co-parenting and
we're learning how to navigate that and
learning what proper boundaries are and
trying to really set those and make sure
you know that jackson knows that he's
loved
when he wants to see his dad when i have
him
i have allowed my door to be open
because i feel that that is healthy
right now for the transition
and as long as we can continue to get
along and i'm really proud of what we're
doing so i think that that's not going
to change well it sounds like there's no
bad blood then between you two at all
there's amazing what would you say
led to this decision i would say not one
single
action led to this decision it was over
a period of time ultimately we're just
different people we want different
things and
you know we were 19 years old when we
fell in love and now we're i'm almost 32
and
life just looks very different and
that's okay it's taken a lot for us to
realize that and accept that that's been
really hard so obviously you know there
comes the decision to split and then
there comes the decision to make it
public and to make that announcement and
you just know i'm sure that that opens
you up to some scrutiny from fans
followers but also family and your dad
did take to instagram uh following your
divorce announcement and he said that
his support for you was quote biblically
based what did you make of that because
he has me blocked on social media i was
just a little
confused by the post there's been many
exchanges and
um we have each other's personal numbers
so i feel that if it was something that
was from a genuine place then
it should have been private and not
on instagram so your dad never reached
out to you privately after you announced
you're getting divorced no okay well he
did talk about it on his podcast as well
were you surprised by his reaction there
you know i get bits and pieces of what
happens on his podcast um
through therapy over the last year i had
just been advised by my therapist to
not tune in to not follow along on
social media things that were being
posted because it's triggering to me
and so
i try to distance myself from that as
much as possible however
i was told many things that have been
said
and it's hard not to
want to respond to those things because
some of the things that
have been said um
either are just categorically false or
maybe the intentions i don't feel are
pure as you know he also did sit down
with e.t
and he did make some claims about you
that i was hoping i could actually get
your reaction to and maybe even add some
clarification um you know todd said that
you texted him around the time that you
announced that you were getting a
divorce i
received a text message from lindsay
about two weeks ago
and i turned that over to our attorneys
why um because we don't feel that it's
safe to communicate i find it odd that
anyone would go out here and make some
of the statements that are allegedly
said on
the podcast
things that have been
posted over the years
and then use the excuse of
i don't feel
comfortable or safe doing that will you
feel safe speaking on me publicly
so
i feel that it would be in the best
interest for everyone to be able to sit
down and you know bring everything to
the table and say you know this is what
it is and
let the pieces fall where they may um
i have extended that courtesy multiple
times and never been taken up on it so
i think that speaks volumes do you feel
like you've done things to harm your
family that warranted him to make it so
straightforward and be like you know
what she texted and i actually just
passed those over to our attorney well
actually
i believe that it was um
it was
made
people were made to believe that it was
multiple texts that were it was a
singular text right and um
the text
had a direction to actually give it to
his attorney so
that's probably what i would have done
as well and i think he knows that i
wouldn't speak to him
without attorneys present anyway so it
was like protocol almost yeah right
um you know in our interview with him
todd described an emotional battle uh
within you there was just some kind of
emotional
battle that lindsay has had within
herself and you know jealousy with
amongst her siblings any truth to that
and where do things stand with you and
your siblings now
there is no jealousy what is there to be
jealous of
i moved away from something that i felt
was toxic and not in my best interest
and encouraged my own path i'm educated
i have my own home i have a beautiful
child i have a great life i have a life
outside of the public eye that i truly
value
and
there's nothing
there's nothing to be
jealous of because they're on a reality
tv show
i'm not envious of anyone who's on
reality tv
you just mentioned that you know it's up
to people to believe what they want to
believe do you feel like your siblings
believe one example taught over you do
you feel like your siblings have sided
with him definitely there's there's been
a line drawn in the sand and um
participation from
siblings to
to go along with the story that
is being sold to anyone who will listen
that's unfortunate there's nothing i can
really
do about that and at the end of the day
it's not
it's not for me to care because i know
i know what the truth is and i know what
the majority of people who have
watched my story and who have listened
to me
know that it's not hard to pick out the
pieces of the puzzle and to make it
match you know your lawyer is on the
call with us and i don't want to get
into the nuts and bolts of these
allegations but of course in the past
you have accused your dad and chase of
extortion and blackmail and so i just
wanted to ask where does that case stand
right now that case is still an
investigation
what we're doing is we're
making sure we have all our ducks in a
row to make sure that lindsay is
protected
we've provided the
information and communication that we
have
to law enforcement
and uh are ready for any questions about
it from law enforcement or the public
lindsay let me ask you this how do you
move on
from that when it comes to your
relationship with your family if at all
i'm not interested
whatsoever um
truthfully it's something that i
probably and this sounds
crazy but it's true
it's something i probably could have
moved past had people been honest about
the entire situation and how it unfolded
at this point do you still talk to
anyone in the family
i don't you don't
no can i ask do you miss them in some
ways i think yes because you know that's
your family but then
in a lot of ways i feel like it's a lot
healthier for me to be
where i'm at
i need to protect my peace and
i don't want to be
drug up in drama all of the time and i
don't
and unfortunately i have been
the
person that drama is always surrounding
because
i'm not a part of them you know and so
i'm the outsider looking in
so i'm always the target in the last
five years had i known
what i know today
i never would have done the show really
because i feel like i'm still
dealing with things
from when i was on the show so many
years ago i haven't been on chris leno's
best since 2017. right and i still feel
like i'm pigeonholed into some of those
storylines and get messages all the time
for people seeing reruns or you know
whatever
um
that it's just not me and so
there's been a lot of learning lessons
and it's not for the faint of heart to
live their life publicly because you do
feel like you owe people an explanation
to a degree
and um
for that
i wish that that was different but
unfortunately it's not and um
you just have to make the best of it i
mean how do you think your life and your
relationship with your family would be
different had you not done the show
that's an interesting question and um i
actually didn't have a relationship
with my family prior to the show so
when that opportunity
came to fruition
it was like everybody
came together to do this and didn't know
what was going to happen with it and
then you know it was like this one big
happy family but up until that point i
was just a college student
living with my boyfriend and had no
communication with my dad or his wife
whatsoever you know your dad also had a
message for you in the podcast too like
i mentioned saying that he was there for
you there for jackson whenever he needs
him well one they don't know my son so
i don't
i don't know how you could be there for
someone that you don't
know they haven't he hasn't seen my son
since he was four years old and he's
gonna be nine at the end of december
together was that
was that your decision or was that his
that was my decision yeah um and
i feel
validated in that and i don't need
public validation you know to to make
that type of decision because ultimately
i'm jackson's mother absolutely
but
with that being said um
i don't see how you say some of the
things that
are said but then in the same
breath say that um
you know you're there you're there for
this person
it's um
it's a bit calculated and manipulating i
think
you